hey really I'm Dave joined by Oscar dais
hello Dave how are you I'm all right
back from Stockholm sort Star Wars bar
front to Peter how was it it was great
it was great video over willing to go
into more details - you're a big star
Wars fan so ask me some questions what
do you want to know first I want to know
what did you actually get to play so we
got I got like four hours and is now
with the Arcade Mode and I always like
to consult an hour with Starfighter
assault and an hour with strike so for
most right talk to me about each of
those in turn in a very boring
monotonous way arcade is is basically I
feel like it's a bit surplus
requirements like you can earn points in
arcade but you're limited to how many
you could earn in a day just so you
can't just go offline farm but really
it's just it's just a way to play
offline as a couple of challenges
involved the biggest draw really is to
is an opportunity to play with like new
loadouts and new weapons and stuff
before you actually jump into the game
right okay it was just it's kinda like a
training mode I guess that was the vibe
I got from it or at least that's I think
the way I would use it for yeah but
that's me
Starfire result we saw at Gamescom still
just as exciting it's had some tweaks to
the HUD Imperium Imperium Imperial
versus rebels Imperium champions of
bloody 4140 a thing my other nerd
selfish oh yeah so his rebels versus
empire rebels destroying the Star
Destroyer same stuff we saw it Gamescom
galactic assault was the main draw that
was 20 V 20 years rabu that their big
draw competitive objective based game
mode that was one they've led with 83
clone troopers versus the separatist
droids that's when you see the big MT T
going down into the into the palace
considering as like episode 1 era it was
actually still quite nice to play
through it because there wasn't any gun
guns it wasn't even in there I was gonna
say a episode one's the best one right
don't dislike this video and then strike
is the smaller competitive mode so it's
8v8 and matt we played was like force
awakens era first orders trying to steal
an artifact get it away in that mode
there's like no heroes there's no
vehicles it's it's much smaller scale
whereas ink
to consult you can have super heavy
classes you can get vehicles you can get
like aircraft and you can obviously get
the heroes yeah yeah so is the it talks
to me about the the vehicle combat is
that similar to the first game where
some of the maps have ships that you can
jump in and go and fight against other
ships or is the obviously staff at
result is or vehicle yeah only Galactica
so I believe has like a big draw for the
vehicle stuff but thankfully they've
changed that really stupid pickup system
about our friend won it like just a
glowing all but yeah token right yeah
yeah yeah run out it and then just get
on your mobile phone and I started
calling stuff in yeah thankfully that's
gone instead they've got a battle point
system which is way better but I still
have a couple of reservations right but
you earn battle points for getting kills
playing the objective doing stuff with
your team basically playing the game the
better you play the game more objective
focused you are the more objectives you
do with more kills you get the more
tokens you you you weren't then you
redeem those tokens in the respawn
screen for vehicles heavy classes and
heroes the thing I'm concerned about is
though is like I don't mean to toot my
own horn but I was playing pretty
decently oh yeah I play games and even
even I struggle to get some of the
heroes and my concern is is that things
like the hero pickups are gonna be
reserved for the people who really know
how to play the game which I feel like
might be unfair yeah like if you're not
great at the game you could still have
an opportunity to experience all of it
yeah every now and again right you don't
want to have like it probably should be
a reward based system so that the best
players do get to play more often but if
you if I like I'm not great issues I'm
okay but if I never get to play as Han
Solo or whoever then you know I'm
probably not going to want to play as as
much as someone else yeah I don't know
how they're gonna tweak it I don't know
how like if in previous games if you're
not great shooting you can still support
your team with with like like in
battlefield you can still support the
team with resurrections and healing kits
and hammer kids I don't know how many
points gonna get for playing the
objective there wasn't really anything
like you know healing kits and stuff
like that yeah so I'm not sure how it's
gonna work but for me at least like I I
was getting super powerful vehicles and
heroes and then because I was playing
really well as those who
powerful heroes of vehicles I was only
one battle points which kind of create a
snowball effect yeah and they were
actually like people playing in the room
that getting really frustrated with it
because they they weren't able to catch
up like because I was there's a walker
which is like super Opie at the minute
like even even the dev said yeah it's a
bit o P we really need to adjust it I
don't know if it's been adjusted for the
beta but I mean they're they're
admitting this two weeks ago so it
should be adjusted for when the game
comes out but if I'm just you know
snowballing through heroes and vehicles
and dominating the map the enemy team
has no real chance to like get some
momentum back yeah that might come in
the way of like new star cards that
could be like super powerful anti
vehicle star cards but then that relies
on people having said star cards and
getting the opportunity to use them but
I mean all that being said it is way
better than a token appearing on the map
yeah and everyone abandoning the
objective to run to the token the first
one gets it and then just strolling up
with an eighty eighty or like running in
a loop and so it might need tweaking but
it is way better I think it's gonna be
something to keep an eye on yesterday
hopefully the beat will allow them if
it's not been tweaked for the beta and
allow them to tweak it yeah for the
actual fight I think it's gonna be
something that we're gonna have to keep
an eye on like I said in the release
rather than the beta because it is I
think it is something that needs to be
seen with like a huge amount people
playing it so you can really get into
the nitty-gritty numbers of it yeah but
still way better than tokens awesome
yeah now you mentioned star cards there
I am dumb and an idiot so talk to me
about star cards what are star cards am
i a star card absolutely a bronze one
I've played the game and I'm still kind
of confused as to what star really but
there are a way to augment your classes
so you can get a star card that will
give you like change one of your class
abilities you can get a star card which
is like a passive ability you can get
them via like there's another game with
a loot crate system so you can earn ho
crates and getting through that and then
excellent stuff you can earn crafting
materials and use those to create or
improve star cards right again it's it's
quite a tricky system yeah because I've
seen some stuff on them but I'm still
kind of confused by them
four hours of the beta but like that
isn't a long time to progress a
character in a lot of star cards so like
similar to about a front one it took a
while for you to get a lot of cards it
could really change your plans yeah yeah
there were a few that could like really
change your class like the heavy you
could just get an average star card
obviously gives you a completely
different ability so there are there are
like different levels of how much you
can change your class sure but then a
it's just you just have to earn them
yeah just gonna take time which you
don't really get yeah that was one of my
main criticisms of the first battlefront
was that it never really felt I was
progressing it was like when I first
jumped in it was amazing it was awesome
in it I was in Star Wars and it was like
the sound was amazing it looked amazing
and wow this is like my childhood dream
come true but then 10 hours later and
I'm still doing the same things and the
buzz was kind of wearing off a little
bit I know you only played a few hours
of it but do you have any sense so far
that the progression is going to be any
better or or you feel like you're gonna
be progressing past just that initial
WoW moment do you think that it is gonna
be deeper than the first game yeah both
in the progression system and that like
and keeping the wow factor alive the
progression system is there is more
depth to it like this tripled the amount
of like classes heroes and vehicles that
you can you know customize and build
upon and the tiered star cards obviously
help with that but really like yeah like
you mentioned like the wow factor kind
of dying down and I actually think the
fact that they have three eras of star
wars helped in that in that manner for
me yeah because like well the the
previous game did have a lot of wow
factor me you were on Hoth and like you
said you saw the walkers and the
snowspeeders that's great but now you
get to like relive that the three eras
so when I was playing as you know the
original trilogy that's like cool x-wing
fighters I can I can get on board of
this I recognize this and then it when
it was in like the prequel to a trilogy
well obviously the movies aren't are
touchy subjects it's still like I
remember this from my childhood this is
like this is like Battlefront to like
seeing like the the Naboo palace yeah
and like you remember how I said why is
the best film yeah
and then it was obviously really cool
like playing as at the first order and
Rea and seeing like new ships from like
the new new trilogy so it's like you get
like three tears of nostalgia yeah any
time how old you are how much you've
seen stars yeah that's great it's like
fun for all the family except with with
blasters and guns yeah it's always fun
it's fine it's fine
great I'm really looking forward to it
but the last thing I want to ask you
about is I'm hoping the sound has not
got any worse because I saw it was like
thinking diamond of all in the first
ever done a game with bad sound yeah
like that sound design is incredible
that was what blew me away in the first
one I remember vividly the first time I
threw it thermal imploder
and it made that yeah yeah it is still
amazing like the sound really is like a
massive source of nostalgia because when
you hear that TIE fighter that screech
and that when you when you're playing as
Darth Maul and you hear the two
lightsaber blades just yeah there's
doubt and even the droids like that that
the droid voice they had and I played
one that's like kind of comedic and you
can hear that going over the the radio
when you're playing on the droids side
all the time it is very much it very
much feels like you're in the Star Wars
universe
yeah even it's even got the same accent
for the clone troopers I can't remember
the actor's name but they all had Jango
Fett's voice yeah yeah that's still the
same is is Jar Jar Binks in it I didn't
see him but it would really wouldn't
surprise me if in a dlc or something I
would love ring out you're a hero
yeah I want to play as Jar Jar Binks
secret seasoning that Theory's
incredible is that I'm all aboard that's
a bit I ain't seen him but it really
wouldn't surprise me if he ended up in
the game or an expansion or something
please dice make it happen those are my
thoughts on well the pizza that I played
at least everyone else is gonna get
their hands on it on October the 6th and
they're totally ordered for the October
for those and then it comes out on
November 17th all right so not that long
no a dose of Star Wars I'm looking
forward to it I'm really looking for
more than I kind of realized
you can play that for a month and then
you go see the next movie in December
awesome season a Star Wars bye boys
yes mate right well for everything else
Star Wars Battlefront 2 and every now
Star Wars really make sure you go to
gamespot.com peace